good evening and welcome to this south
east area planning committee on 13th
october 2021 my name is councillor
vanessa bell and i'm chairman of this
committee
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for kovis
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
2nd of september 2021 in the interest of
members and officers safety
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hands up to indicate if
you wish to speak and i will invite you
at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube livestream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones as we
have seen by my epic fail at the
beginning of the meeting
therefore can i ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind this top table
item two apologies for absence now have
the apologies please werner
thank you chairman we've received an
apology for absence from cancer skins
you very much
oh council channel
uh thank you madam chairman i just said
if i leave the meeting at any stage and
don't return it's nothing personal or
anything you've said just give a full
warning in case i need to do that thank
you
thank you councillor shannon of girls
item three minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
15th of september 2021 found on pages 7
to 16 are approved as a true and
accurate record
am i so moved do i have a seconder for
that motion
that's the voice
thank you
uh does any member wish to raise any
matter of accuracy
lovely
can we agree those by ascent members
please
agreed thank you marvelous
item for declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
any
cancer stamp
um thank you madam chair just that i'm a
member of essex county council which are
consultees on some of the applications
thank you councillor yeah thank you
chairman um
i
at a gender item seven the applicant is
an occasional customer of mine i don't
think it's prejudicial but i will leave
the room nevertheless thank you thank
you very much councillor
members i'll take that as uh
as all thank you
that brings us on to item five
twenty zero one one nine one full which
is hall farm hall farm road south
minster essex and this can be found on
pages 17 to 34 of your agenda pack
presenter is catherine matthews so if i
can hand over to you ms matthews please
thank you chairman
good evening members
so this is um an application for a
change of use of south winter hall to a
mixed use providing a wedding ceremony
room residential use and the change of
use of salesman tour grounds to provide
a wedding venue to include citing a
marquee and toilets
and ancillary parking and conversion of
an outbuilding to an ancillary bridal
suite
so this slide shows the location of the
application site which is in the rural
area to the south of hall road and to
the east of the settlement of south
minster
the site currently accommodates a
residential dwelling and associated land
to the north site on the opposite side
of hall road is um pandora and
wood sorry
an open countryside to the east is land
and buildings also owned by the
applicant to the west is gold's hand
road and to the south are existing
buildings in commercial use
south mentho railway station is just
over 200 metres to the west
and with the centre of southminster
beyond there are residential properties
in the vicinity of the site
and a later slide will show you where
the nearest ones are
the existing vehicle accesses site is
from hall road
um
and that will be retained and used as
part of the development
so this slide
you can see where south meets railway
station is for those who don't know
southeastern
and it's an aerial photo showing the um
the application site
um golsan road here and hall road along
the northern boundary and the existing
dwelling at south minster hall
and this is a proposed block plan so
this shows where the marquee would be
positioned
where the the toilet facility would be
provided
and the building that would be converted
into a bridal suite
and got a small part of the existing
dwelling to be used as a ceremony room
and you've got the um car park area
proposed to the west with the access
point on the northern boundary there
so these are some it's illustrative
parking layout just to demonstrate how
many spaces that could be provided
within that space
they have shown 90 in that space there
there would be a one-way system around
there will be one-way system around the
car parking for um taxis
to use um
and this also includes a swept path
analysis which shows how vehicles would
enter and leave the site this
information was only received uh
yesterday
uh yesterday and the
highways authority have been reconsulted
on the application and they have since
um it was too late for the update
unfortunately but they have now
recommended approval raise no objections
subject to conditions
and this plan as i mentioned earlier
shows the location of the nearest
existing residential properties
and so
we've got three um residential
properties here to the south
and um we also the other nearest ones
are um these on hall road up here and
this 20 hall road is um based on the
advice enrollment health officer the
residential property or resident
occupiers that are most likely to be
affected by
potential noise from the
wedding venue
so this is the ceremony room
showing the um locator i mean it's just
an existing room within the house
and then on the left hand side there is
the proposed layout of the bridal suite
which would be two bedrooms um
and a living area and a kitchen
so these are existing proposed
elevations of the bridal suite so very
little in terms of changes there to the
appearance of the existing building
you've got images no example of what the
marquee
is intended to look like and the toilets
and some photos of the um the houses the
hall there the building that's going to
be converted to bridal suites
and we've got some more distant um
photos these were provided by the
applicant
showing the position of the
marquee
with hull road there on the left hand
side on the top photo and the right hand
side on the bottom photo
um
just to mention that especially um
inheritance and conservation has raised
no objections
and um the
existing vegetation would help to screen
marquee and the parking from public view
so in conclusion the proposal would
result in economic benefits for the
local area and the district no
objections are raised to the principle
of the development
it will not cause harm to or harm to the
current appearance of the area as a
result of the marquee and parking area
proposed furthermore the proposal will
not have a harmful impact on this
locally listed building or its setting
and subjects the impetition of
conditions would not have a materially
adverse impact on the immunity of local
residents
no objections are raised in relation to
highway safety access and parking
and maybe this is an opportunity just to
highlight the conditions that are
recommended by the highways authority
and they're um
so that requires the reconstruction of
the field access as shown on those um
drawings that i said had been received
yesterday
and so that's requiring a width of at
least six meters
and um
there'll be no obstruction um above two
point four meters so
parallel band visibility display either
side of the access
and the final one will be no unbound
material used in the the first six
meters of the axis from the highway
and unlike that basis um officers
recommend that plan permission is
granted notably only for a temporary
period and
and
thank you for your time thank you
thank you very much ms matthews now we
do have a public participant for this
planning application
so in line with the public participation
scheme i now invite the agent ms
jennings please to read out your
submission
and may i remind you that you are
allocated to meet two minutes in
accordance with this game
so whenever you're ready ms jennings
thank you chairman i won't take up much
of your time as captain has already
provided a clear summary of the proposal
southminster hall is an imposing
victorian farmhouse but it is in need of
significant works to maintain it the
main driver behind this project is the
need to generate an income to fund the
much needed repairs and refurbishment
the proposal also importantly provides a
farm diversification and a job
opportunity for the younger members of
the family farming business
proposal for the wedding venue has been
well received in the preliminary
advertising that the applicants have
done at wedding fairs throughout the
year
there is a lot of interest in this
property as a wedding venue as trends
move towards more unique venues and
marquee type venues
the main impacts of noise and traffic
have been carefully considered in this
proposal as set out by the officer
the applicants have confirmed that they
are happy to invest significant funds in
the specialist speakers that will
minimise any noise outside of this site
technological advances mean that it's
now possible to have speakers they can
direct noise to specific areas and
prevent it soaking out into the wider
atmosphere
malden council have approved this type
of noise attenuation at other wedding
venues that are operating in the
district
so we know it works well
in terms of highway impact as um has
been stated highways have no objection
following the recent plans that have
been sent through
and the site is also close to the train
station and bus stop so we do anticipate
that not all vehicles will be car based
traffic
heritage have also confirmed they have
no concerns with the proposal at
southminster hall i would however raise
concern about the two-year time limit at
no point was there any discussions on
the proposal being temporary as the
owners have a business plan stretching
far beyond this two-year time limit
the proposed condition too adds
significant uncertainty to this business
model
it appears that this time limited time
limitation has appeared because of the
temporary nature of the wc facilities
marquee proposed
all other aspects of this application
have been
approved and i would ask that you
consider extending the time limit if
indeed it is considered necessary thank
you very much
thank you very much miss jennings
um now would any other officers like to
speak i think in light of what ms
jennings has just requested regarding
the condition it would be helpful
yes um
the the reasons for the um
to your
time limit was um
partly because the um the marquee is is
a temporary type of structure which
wouldn't ordinarily be
appropriate to be permanently approved
um there are whilst um every effort has
been made to satisfy environmental
health and highways and there is an
element of
site element of unknown so the two-year
period will give an opportunity for the
impact of the use of the site as a
wedding venue to be assessed and then if
any further mitigation measures are
required there'll be an opportunity to
require them um at a subsequent
date you know
when their
further application was was submitted
um
so
they're the reasons for the temporary i
do appreciate the two years
isn't a particularly long time period
for for a business but
um it's uh long enough um but the
thinking behind it was long enough to
get at least
two um summer seasons in for the for the
wedding venue to um give it some time to
establish and at the same time give the
council opportunity to
um review the uh impact of it and and
reconsider it at the end of that
period thank you so can i just clarify
after the two-year period would that
then have to come back again as a new
application with all the um
associated costs for the applicants
the way the work the have been worded
then yes the permission would expire in
two years time unless um an application
had been made to extend that period um
so there would be a cost in making that
application um you know be an
application fee to pay
um
in terms of um additional costs that
then the drawings i would imagine would
be the same as as they are now they
might be tweaked slightly
um
but i don't
can't think of any any sort of
supplementary document or something that
would be um required then that
hasn't already been provided that would
mean that the um
significant extra cost would be would be
incurred
thank you
any other officers like to add anything
okay
members oh sorry
sorry i was
i was also just going to say in terms of
the temporary permission
because it allows for that
opportunity to review the impact
obviously
if impacts do emerge then there may be
some
additional costs but obviously
that it's very hard to make that
judgment until
if there are any impacts what they are
and what their nature is
thank you very much for that
council
thank you very much chairman um
you'll obviously know that i'm the ward
member so with council beale as well so
first of all i'd just like to thank
officers for listening to the concerns
that i raised on behalf of residents who
who live in station road and tash shores
and cherry orchard all regarding noise
german i mean i i think it's fair to say
the local people want this to succeed
because i think the agents have to be
right it does provide an opportunity a
much needed opportunity for employment
in the village but noise is a big
concern um however i know this
application is for temporary permission
and i think that certainly gives uh mems
of the public a lot of comfort
um because
the even though the applicant has gone
to uh extraordinary lengths to uh
to mitigate noise
and provide various boundaries to stop
the noise progressing you know we really
do need to understand and i think that
if temporary consent is granted then all
parties including the applicant um will
be able to satisfy themselves that it is
suitable for this uh location so i would
very much support the the temporary uh
aspects of this um
if um if i could just go on to
conditions there is just something that
concerns me
and this is the
um condition number six and i hope i've
got these around the right ways
um
i'd like to propose and i mean uh
yeah i'd like to propose an amendment to
condition number six
on the basis that condition 13 states
that the venue must be cleared by
midnight
so i get that so the venue has to be
cleared by midnight however condition
six
6
says that
amplified music
can take place between 11am and 11 30.
so chairman my proposal would be to
change that from 11am to
11am to 11 p.m which would allow for an
extra 30 minutes for for guests to leave
the site uh in an orderly manner because
i think that's important we all know
station road so to leave in an ordinary
manner and also allow the contractors
and entertainers and everybody else an
extra half an hour to clear up and
hopefully chairman that that would then
mean that by midnight everybody really
would have had plenty of time to get off
rather than half-past them and close the
site down and then you get you know
hopefully you know the car parked with
90 cars 180 people jumping in their cars
and and rushing off which would
certainly not be fair to the people who
stationed her so i think there's a way
of restricting the disturbance to
certainly before 12 midnight so chen if
if the committee were mindful to accept
that then i would propose that we we
agree the officer's recommendation uh
subject to that particular change thank
you
thank you a half an hour does seem a
very short time frame to completely get
all the guests and contractors and
everybody associated out of venue i do
appreciate that do i have a second uh
counselor bill
seconding
okay remember this is something we can
help cancer voice
thank you chairman without wishing to
upset the ward members
on this i'd like to explore this
um temporary condition
said they're happy with it
um
but reading it which is condition one
the site is restored to its current
condition there is some permanent
um
we were told by the applicant's agent
and the
one of the reasons for for this is to
refurbish
the victorian the old victorian
farmhouse
is this condition saying that any
alterations to the permanent
the bridal suite and
any restoration to the building would
have to be restored to its present
condition
going to hand over to offices thank you
councilmance um
thank you
councillor boyce that's a very helpful
and useful um
issue that you've raised and um on the
back of that i would suggest that or
recommend that the condition is changed
so that
it the it's only the use that
in return it returns to residential use
and any physical works to the buildings
um do not have to be undone at the end
of the two-year period
and and yeah and so that is the
temperature removed and the use
reverting back to residential use um
rather than all the works um
including the physical changes to the
rival suite can remain beyond the
two-year period
council boys thank you
i'll just ask if that's acceptable to
the world members
chairman because they have moved a
proposition
and this is changing or would change
their proposition
would members
what happy with that
okay
it does look from the um from what i
could see that the actual
hall itself just remains unchanged and
that the uh
it's the uh the building the outbuilding
the bridal suite that will
will be altered somewhat so i think
we have a proposal to it could just
clarify
council helm i'm sorry you were hidden
behind my camera then
my mask and behind your mask i could
barely see you madam chairman anyone in
business would know that two years
temporary permission for the kind of
money that they've got to spend to get
this up to where they want to get it
the banks will turn them down because
it's long enough
i suggest an extension to at least three
years temporary permission if that's
acceptable
what do we think committee
council flicker well chairman i i i i
did notice that nobody's counseling can
you tell if you microphone please
thank you
i didn't notice nobody rushed to uh to
second that but i would ask members to
bear in mind
how many people live very close to this
tattoo so as you all know is one of the
most densely populated places in the
district not just southminster so
there's a huge amount of people affected
by this and i think two years um gives
gives the opportunity to see what the
effects likely to be my hope is that
there's enough mitigation measures in
place but we need to test that and i
think two years is a far better period
than three
so i wouldn't support that chairman no
thank you thank you i'm going to go to
you counselor bill as the other ward
member for your opinion on that
thank you so that's councillor bill
supporting the two years you're going to
be a microphone on councilman that's
okay
did anyone wish to second councillor
helms amendment
okay
so i think now we've all we've only
amended proposal first
the original one
the first proposal so the first proposal
is to accept the officer's
recommendation
as it stands i believe with it
with the clarification
on the amendment on condition six
conditions apologies amendments on
condition six which is to close at 11
rather than 11 30 and condition one
so
members
do can do we want to vote on that or are
we yes because we have to okay so
berna i will hand over to you
okay members
thank you chair we're voting for the
officer's recommendation to approve the
application subject to the amendments to
both conditions one and six as discussed
i will call your names in alphabetical
order
please stay clearly for against or
abstain
starting with counselor passenger
or
councillor duik
thank you members that's 10 for the
proposal
thank you very much
and no abstentions thank you very much
thank you thank you members
so we move on now to
thank
you so we move on to item six twenty one
zero zero one nine three full
land adjacent to clifford's farm burnham
road old thorn essex
there is a members update
members for this item
and presenting will be
louise staplehurst
so again we do have public participants
for this planning application so um once
the staplehurst has
presented i will invite
members of the public to speak
i will hand over first of all
trying to give you some time to get to
work get to the table with staples so
when you're ready over to you
first of all and please note the members
update which includes consultation
responses from highways and suds
who both have no objections
additional public comments and updated
conditions taking into account
their consultation responses
this application proposes the
construction of 13 dwellings in total
eight affordable dwellings and five
detached market dwellings
the eight affordable units would be in
the form of two blocks of flats in the
western part of the site with four units
in each building
the detached market dwellings would
front the road in the eastern part of
the site
three accesses are proposed one to the
flats one to the dwellings and a
separate one in between the market and
affordable housing which will be used to
access the agricultural fields to the
south
a footpath is proposed at the site
frontage to join the existing pedestrian
network
a large proportion of soft landscaping
is proposed within the site
however no specific details of planting
have been provided with the application
the housing mix will be as follows
four one-bedroom units which will be
affordable for two-bedroom units which
will be affordable and five four bedroom
units which the market dwellings
so this is the location plan showing the
site outlined in red on the southern
side of burnham road just outside of the
settlement boundary of all thorn
this is the block plan showing the two
affordable
flat buildings on the western side of
the site and the market dwellings on the
eastern side of the site
and the access to the fields
in the center to the south
these are the floor plans and elevations
of flat building one this contains four
flats two one bedroom units and two two
bedroom units with the ground floor
units being a wheelchair accessible
design
these are the floor plans and elevations
of flat building 2.
there are slight design amendments
externally but internally it's the same
layout as flat building one
these are the elevations and floor plans
for house type a which is located on
plot one and is a four bedroom dwelling
with an attached double garage
the plans for house type b which will be
on plot two and four
and again is a four bedroom dwelling
with an attached double garage
the plans for house type c which will be
located on plot three
and four bedrooms with an integral
garage for two cars
and house type d which will be located
on plot five um again with four bedrooms
um
no attached garage but there is a
detached garage
the plans for which are shown here
as well as the refuse and cycle store
which will be positioned to the frontage
of the flats
this street scene plan shows the
detached dwellings
and the flats and how they would appear
from burnham road
some photographs showing the view
towards the northern boundary of the
site
and the view looking north east along
the road
sort of heading out of althorn
some photos showing the view along the
northwest of the site and the site
frontage
and some photos showing the neighbouring
dwellings which include similar design
features to the proposed dwellings and
the view across the road towards manchin
house farm to the northeast
the development has been assessed as
being acceptable when taking into
account the substantial benefits of the
proposal which would outweigh the
conflict that the development would have
with the ldp in terms of the
inaccessible location and impact on the
countryside
in particular this relates to the volume
of affordable housing proposed in a
locality within the district where it
has previously been difficult to deliver
affordable housing which would weigh
heavily in favor of the development
the applicant has also agreed to enter
into a section 106 agreement to address
matters of affordable housing and rams
it's therefore recommended for approval
thank you chairman
thank you very much the staple host for
that so as mentioned we do have some
public participation so i will now
invite
mr burgess first of all to speak please
and may i remind you that you are
allocated two minutes so mr burgess
please
and when you are ready we will start the
clock
okay uh it's working yes i think we can
hear you thank you
really yes okay
uh this application is unsustainable
with flawed housing and inadequate
sewage disposal
a tilted balance is used to justify
approval
this is irrelevant it is contrary to
national policy a planning inspectorate
appeal dated 25th of august 2021 states
there appears to be a consistent
conclusion over a sustained period that
all thorn is not to be regarded as a
sustainable location for housing growth
consequently the proposal would not
accord with the overarching spatial
strategy and objectives to sustainably
locate new housing development
affordable housing is not social housing
it is financial engineering for a market
offer
allthorn is 82 percent owner occupied it
has an excess of affordable band-aid
dwellings 25 against a district average
of six a local housing needs assessment
albeit ten years ago mainly reflected a
desire to trade up or leverage equity
release not demand affordable housing
at 62 percent the affordable housing
content is pure window dressing
no registered provider is nominated nor
was there one at nearby burnham waters
which was not financially viable
post approval there
a revision was requested by the
developer think greenland the advisor
here with development rights over the
whole field express a request for
reconfiguration
the development is not connectable to
the main sewer it lies below the gravity
fall line
sewage disposal requires a sump and pump
system this is not specified
this application is based on obfuscation
not reality it should be refused
thank you very much
well within time
so i also have um
parish counsellor
mr terry inc pen
please
when you're ready mr
answering pen i do apologize thank you
is this working okay
yeah we can hear you okay i'm speaking
as a representative althorn parish
council
um
this is
the application the criticism of this
application starts with much of the
information on the documents such as the
application form and the design and
access statements being incorrect or
misleading including for example bus
services and distance to facilities and
services available in the village
presumably this is all aimed at
improving the
apparent sustainability of the site the
whole of all thorn is unsustainable
anyway as evidenced by the fact that in
all thorn from 2013 to 2017
there have been 22 applications for new
dwellings 17 in total refused including
10 after appeals
in all except one unsustainable location
was one of the reasons for rejection
this lack of sense that the
sustainability is significant as to the
other five-year housing land supply
there's a presumption in favor of
sustainable development but this this
site is clearly not sustainable
the site is also outside the village
development envelope a factor that has
contributed to the refusal of three
other applications within 50 metres of
this site in recent years
the three new access points directly
onto the increasingly busy burnham road
for what could be 20 more cars will add
to the congestion and hazards on our
local roads
because there's no doubt that with the
lack of facilities and poor transport
most journeys will be made by car
one of the features of the poor
infrastructure in the village is the
inadequate sewage system
two or three times a year residents in
the north of the village are inundated
with several inches of sewage diluted
with rainwater
angry water are aware of these problems
and how they can say in their response
to this application the system is
adequate to cope with the extra
development is incredible
we believe that the choice made but made
to approve the application by the
planning officer in a very detailed
study between the attraction of eight
more affordable hounds and the harm to
the village that will result sorry
so we then moved to the applicant's
agent mr stuart herrera please
sorry canceling pen i need you to
thank you so whenever you're ready mr i
will start the top
good evening madam chairman and good
evening members i'm stuart rowe planning
consultant and the agent for the
applicant georgina mchugh
members will be very aware of the
current lack of a five-year housing land
supply and the ramifications of this for
decision making i'm not going to lecture
the committee on that matter i think
you're very well aware of that
a raft of applications will be coming
forward for housing most of them outside
settlement boundaries most of them will
propose low numbers of dwellings uh and
many will be in unsustainable locations
however as members are aware each
application is considered on its merits
individually it must be weighed in the
planning balance so the refusal for uh
planning permission in one location even
nearby actually doesn't mean that
another one has to be refused as well it
has to be it has to be weighed each and
every one and i say this because i'm
aware of the refusals locally and in
particular
for example there was one 14 units not
too long ago at winterdale manor
not very far away now that scheme was
considered when the council had a
five-year housing land supply
and the settlement boundaries then
prevailed
which of course they don't now
the housing mix there didn't represent
what was required locally there were
issues with the design and layout it was
a fairly suburban proposal uh it was
recommended for refusal and members
agreed with that whereas the current
application i think is very different is
predicated upon the housing needs in all
thorn
there's research
to support that some of which is based
on the council's own documents it
proposes affordable housing
that meets specific needs
of the district uh the development is a
linear layout so it reflects the
character nearby so i accept that all
thorn isn't the most sustainable
location uh the report makes that point
it accepts it and so do i
but that isn't a killing blow i don't
think i think you have to balance that
against all of the benefits arising from
the scheme your officers have weighed
those benefits in that planning balance
and consider that it tilts in favor of
granting planning permission
there's a recommendation of approval and
i hope the members can support that
thank you thank you well timed mr
and um
councillor shannon um madame chairman if
i need to but i will adjust number two
anyway i'm gonna trust you an arms house
charity nearby thank you thank you very
much and council hell hi also
also elves house yeah
thank you
okay then that brings us to a counselor
maurice who is our final speaker
councillor mauricio
two minutes
thank you very much madam chairman um i
find myself a little bit undone by the
previous uh sorry the
chairman
point of order chairman councillor
morris is not a member of this committee
speaking as a member of the public he he
is not um i think we've used up the
amount of
uh speakers for the public with the two
uh with a parish council representative
and a member of the public
so many and
taking advice
well my understanding chairman sorry
somebody's got a microphone i'm sorry uh
my understanding was that uh council
morris applied to to speakers yeah he
did it remember and you've used it an
attendance member and i've
used my discretion as the chair of the
committee so councillor morris please go
ahead
maya begin again please chair
yes i think we'll start again please
chairman sorry point to order
that's a shannon you i think you just
said you used your discretion to allow
him as an in attendance member whereas
i did take advice earlier because mr
morris did
mr morris councillor morris did formally
approach me
and request permission as from me as
chair to speak so why they've been
insulted
as an in
under what that would be and it is in
fact an inattendance member so i'm still
learning the ropes on who's who and
what's what but i understand that is
acceptable that council morris speaks as
an inattendance member
yes that that's part of the regulations
yes
thank you so council maurice so now the
denji mafia have tried to assassinate me
i'll begin
um the first two speakers were um
excellent and have undone me quite a bit
but i find myself in a position again
where uh i'll be saying what everyone
else is thinking i'm just wondering that
um
has the dengue mafia turned out to
support their commodore and his motley
crew
and um
it might be it might be disgraceful in
someone's eyes but it's truthful i
wonder if this has got anything to do
with commodore with our friend the
commodore uh madam chairman i don't have
to refer to my chairman's protocol i'm
afraid
madame chairman i want it recorded that
i find the comments made totally
offensive and unacceptable
and i'd like you to record it
for me
i'm
don't talk to me you've got no integrity
madam chairman if this is not controlled
i will leave this meeting
penny
attendant
derogatory comments regarding members of
staff or
councillors it
is my responsibility as the chair to
take action
so
sorry
madam chairman i've got total respect
for you in the chair today
but i will speak my truth and i am
saying what a lot of people are thinking
now i'm prepared to shut my mouth and
let the meeting carry on
i do have to give you a warning but um
i'm sorry what are you warning me about
no
unacceptable behavior and how have i
been unacceptable when i'm just speaking
my truth breaches of the
breaches of the
british of the code of conduct uh sorry
you cannot
um judge a breach of the code of conduct
it needs to go to joint standards if you
want to take me there again that's not a
problem but i will say my truth i don't
want to suspend the meeting this is an
important application and i would like
the meeting to continue please
so may i may i request that
that's it now
please
that's nice
councillor bell thank you thank you
so if we may continue the meeting now
please members
i've completely lost where i am
i believe now
that we go back to any officers who may
wish to speak again yeah yep please
nobody else wishes to say anything so i
will throw it open to i said officers
cancel stamp sorry so i will now
i will now throw it over to members
council voice you wish to speak
thank you chairman i've had an argument
with my co-world members but who's to
speak first
um
i was going to go to ward members
without a voice so um
i think uh this this application
uh it is a well argued
case that the officers make
but
it and i take the point that was made by
the uh applicant agent
uh and i think the officer that each
application is
assessed on its merits
in my view
this application has no merits
because it is in an unsustainable
position
now i've heard and understood the
arguments about
the
unsustainability being mitigated by the
affordable housing
i have always advocated that hawthorne
requires some affordable
housing
but
uh and this is a cliche perhaps but this
isn't the right position
for affordable housing
um
several
and the agent again referred
to the other refusals which is in the
past which
dealing with this application on its own
merits
i believe i am able to refer
to the planning application
uh refusals
and subsequent appeals that have been
dismissed
because of
unsustainability there was two opposites
and one was mentioned
the winterdale
manor one which in my view
is in a sustainable position because it
is on a half hour bus route
this application site
is not nearby winterdale manor it is
quite some distance away
and if people in affordable housing have
not booked public transport
it will be nearer for them almost nearer
for them to walk to burnham than to walk
um to the bus to
the bus stops
um
the issue of uh drainage now angry and
walter have said that they can deal with
it
um perhaps they can
um
it goes to mainland
summer hill i've represented all thorn
for nearly 40 years
and summer hill
has always had a problem with
surcharging sewage
down it
in fact on one occasion i went to one
property
uh that had 18 inches of sewage inside
the property because it was set down
it's the old chapel
uh in author
anglian water made provisions to prevent
that happening again but it still
surcharges
um so for those reasons
i
have to
consider going against the officer
recommendation thank you chairman thank
you councillor boyce can i go to other
ward members
please counselor
thank you madam chairman um i i i concur
with with pretty much everything that
councillor boyce has said and there's a
few other sort of aspects to this
um the officer's report says there would
be some change of character to the area
well if you look at the plan itself i
mean we're looking at a field really
and uh if you put a housing small
housing estate on a field i wouldn't say
that is some small character change to
the area i would say that is a massive
character change to the area
also with the views that we saw they all
seem to be along the road and different
views but there isn't one that actually
shows you the view from the road looking
down to the river crouch which is
which is a spectacular view and has been
enjoyed by everyone for years and years
and again you put a block of
houses in front of that well that is a
change to the rural character i would
say
um i would also like to say about the uh
unsustainability as council boyce said
you know there is absolutely no way you
can use the station there is one bus
that comes through that through all
thorn once a day at nine o'clock in the
morning and that goes towards burnham so
there's no public transport at all
there's very very limited paving
and also this development i think has
something like 34 parking spaces
included in it
so again we're looking at an
environmental issue here we are bringing
all of these cars all possibly all of
these cars at least 20 cars into this
environment so again we have a huge
environmental change of character i
would say
um i would also like to look at the
design i think as well and we've got
affordable houses and unaffordable
houses as far as i'm concerned or maybe
not you call them market houses
certainly not social housing and it does
say i think somewhere whereas 5.4.2
that good design is fundamental to high
quality new development
okay
uh permission should be refused
for development of poor design
okay so when you look at affordable
housing and unaffordable housing one's
exotic i imagine
sort of design qualities and we'll have
boarding and we'll have windows that
look great and all design
whatever
and the other two the two blocks will be
two brick block
blocks
that's what they will be they will be
affordable housing they will two blocks
of flats basically
so i don't see how
they
look the same as the affordable so the
unaffordable will not look the same as
the unaffordable
so we have two very different types of
building in fact just just by the
statement one is blocks of flats the
other ones are houses
so again
that i think is is the design issue i
have that they are poorly designed
um certainly um as councilor boys said
the sewage issue in all thorns being
atrocious and only recently there was
flooding again
the other thing i'd like to say is i
think this whole application is based on
an old housing assessment from what i
can see and i know they're saying we
shouldn't regard this because this
application was put in but
is it the lhna concludes that the
district has a need for small dwellings
and these smaller dwellings would be two
to three bedroom houses this application
is all based on fact that we would get
one to two bedroom houses so we're not
actually getting what is required and
that's a bit like saying you know we
need to go from a to b
at this stage but now it's changed and
people need to go from b to a but hey
forget that we'll go from a to b because
that's what we've decided to do
rather than then acknowledging the fact
that the goal posts have changed and we
are now looking for two to three bedroom
houses we do not have a requirement for
one to two bedroom houses
so all in all i actually would like to
say that i totally would like to
refuse this application based on
sustainability i don't think it has any
economic benefits for the area and i
think
it would be devastating to the character
of the area as well and by the way we
are tearing up something like i don't
know how many hundred feet of hedgerow
which i know they're gonna pay a hundred
and something quid to mitigate it in
some way but to me i think killing off
the habitat destroying the hedgerows to
put a little housing estate which
actually will do nothing
to really relieve the five-year land
supply that we are so desperately trying
to
to fulfill
to me this is absolutely a flawed
application and i'd like to propose that
we refuse it
thank you very much
councillor bassinger members
oh who's my voice anybody else like to
speak
sorry as councillor passenger that was a
proposal wasn't it so
i have a seconder for that proposal
sorry bear with
okay sorry bear with me uh mr lee is
going to come back on the reasons for
refusal so over to you yesterday see you
chairman um just hoping to make sure
got them
there's quite a lot in here
obviously obviously
you're the one that gives the puts
forward the refusal so i'm just trying
to comment on some of the points you
made so then hopefully we can
collectively
formulate what you're proposing then
obviously there's a second uh we can
move forward on that um
in relation to sustainability um
what i'd obviously advise members is
that the office report quite happily
acknowledges that the site isn't
sustainable um it acknowledges the
previous recent refusal um
and you know inspectors have agreed that
size and sustainable um
what
the point of this application is is that
we've got no five-year land supply until
it balance comes into play and officers
taking into account the social economic
environmental aspects of the five of the
uh mppf and considering the balance and
exercise that social benefits of having
a
higher percentage of affordable housing
out outweighs the conflict with the
environmental aspects in relation to the
impact on the care of the area which you
know as the officer paul explains
happens with any development which is
certain center level of neutrality with
that we have to show i would say a
exceptional impact but
that comes back to subjectivity i'll
move on to that slightly and in relation
to the economic benefits i think it'd be
very dangerous to say there were no
economic benefits for the simple fact
that as you've seen every appeal
decision inspector acknowledges with any
development there is some economic
benefit benefits through even if
temporarily the construction etc we see
that repeated in every appeal decision
so i'd be very worried if we as a
council said there were no economic
benefits because that would go clearly
against what every appeal even for
single house says so um
for that tilted balance i'd be very
worried if we said there were no
economic benefits um
in relation to impact on the areas of
saying
any development on any
field will have some level of uh impact
term and that's what the office support
is trying to say that you know there is
some impact
um it's on pat cappy maybe it's limited
you know that is a subjective point
members don't agree with that um that's
within your gift um that is up to
yourselves as the decision makers in
relation to the sewage though what i
would flag up is that you know the
statute consult here said it's
acceptable without having any evidence
to uh
go against their stance it would be very
dangerous i would advise for members to
state that you know you've all heard me
say it a hundred times you know if we've
got technical expert advisors that
something's acceptable unless we have
somebody technical to go against it
we're going to be in a very difficult
position with the reason refusal for
that um anecdotal information is not
enough to stand up to against a
statutory council t saying something's
okay so i
would um
be concerned about that
um
also the statement it doesn't do
anything to relieve the five-year land
supply the end of the day this is a
major application it's full so it would
go straight into the five-year land
supply figures
so you might say it's not a particularly
big benefit but say nothing would be
dangerous as well because there is some
unlike an outline application for a
large amount of housing actually might
not actually feed anything into the
five-year land supply this application
would put some figures into so to say
nothing once again is just
a little bit too weighted one way which
would put us in a dangerous position and
appeal because you're not we're not
taking a reasonable position in relation
to the benefits and the waiting process
i think while there was other things
said i think they were the main points
he's proposed around reasons for refusal
i think chairman
i believe design um counselor
i would like to add my concerns that i i
looking at the drawings might again
subjective and i understand it always is
but it did look like a red
block plonked in the middle of the
countryside from the drawings and i'm
hard to tell again subjective yeah
chairman i'll say yeah that is a
subjective point you know if members
don't think designers are acceptable
standard that's within their gift to
come to that conclusion um as i said you
know when it comes to objective matters
i said before you know that is you know
i'm quite happy for members to you know
buyers but at the end of the day you can
fall on either side of the fence to a
certain extent the only issues i would
raise are where we're making statements
that are either incorrect as in it
wouldn't have any benefit to economic or
five-year land supply or where we're
going to go against a taxi console t
without having demonstrable evidence but
otherwise
members the other points are within your
gift thank you thank you very much so
councillor bassinger back to you would
you um
would you consider
changing those slightly at all
absolutely um duchenne would you like
some assistance
please
i think taking into account what kant
sebastian said roughly um
obviously what i would suggest is that
right
i'll i'll be rather getting ahead about
yourself
my own my understanding counselor boys
and i've just been involved i was just
advised by mr lee is that we need to
firm up the reasons on which the
proposal to refuse is based before we
get to a seconder am i correct mr m
that's as count as members will be aware
from the recent training
by myself and more importantly uh mr
quelch in relation to this matter there
is case law that says that members when
they should have a clear precise reason
for refusal before entering into a vote
and things yeah thank you
changing rules council voice i think
though
please um chariot counsel stan yeah
chairman can i ask that we carry on
debating what could i ask councillor um
passenger i'm going to call him mark
just so we can carry on debating it
before we actually make a proposal if if
you if that's reasonable members does
anybody else feel like that
could be the reason
or not yeah but it's debating
we are we are in the position where
council passenger has put a proposal so
we need to
if councillor bassinger wishes to pull
that proposal we may carry on debating
but if he does not then
we carry on as we were going as we were
going german i feel like
the good amaze professor said united
but we can carry on debating yeah
yes so we need to we need to continue to
firm up for the proposal with the
reasons back in the secondary if so and
then move back to the debates yeah
thank you
thank you officers
duchenne i would say it's a council
that's taking into account your points
and up hopefully you can take into
account what way i would advise you to
give these
i'd advise that your
primary reason seems to be the impact on
the character the area including the
design of the proposed development
one in relation to
the sustainability of the site
um which obviously you know officers
wouldn't disagree with but it comes up
to the balancing exercise and
obviously there was one about no
economic benefits i wouldn't advise
members included that one in relation to
sewage which i'd also advise we wouldn't
include
and i wouldn't actually say lack of a
five-year-old answer or how when it
would actually form these pews when it's
out and it would have been a material
consideration so they would be the four
that i would say you put forward and
obviously you've got my comments about
the merits of the four of them thank you
chairman
thank you mr lee back to you
thank you mr chair
mr chair mrs chair madam chairman uh mr
lee i mean thank you very much and yes i
will accept
those and then
i think we should then as we've all
agreed accept those the first proposal
and continue the debate
so we do need a second that we do need a
secondary i want to go back to
i'm slightly confused here because um mr
lee has advised that saying no
impact would be inadvisable and no
benefit so i'm just no impact would be
advisable as far as i understood impact
on countries
using a definitive such as no was it for
each my advice was in relation i would
you know the first two weeks refusal you
know impact on capital area slash design
you know that's a subjective point i
don't think you know the officers were
poor acknowledges the lack of
sustainability so i wouldn't have any
issue that all i said is i wouldn't
encourage members to either
look for reason for user on
no economic benefits because you know
and also i wouldn't recommend uh
members to look to refuse on sewage
because we don't the statute console t
so if members wish to go on the first
two you know they're planning merit the
second two i would be concerned about
those matters thank you thank you mr lee
so council business are we happy to go
on the first two yes but we could
possibly add on minimal economic
benefits
minimal
i'd advise that wouldn't this be a
reason for refusal it just weighs
against the development so rather than
yeah i just i don't think it stands up
on its own as a reason for refusal
okay i'm willing to accept those two
thank you very much do i have a second
of a council of passengers most dumb
motion to refuse with those
thank you of course now my understanding
is that it is to refuse on the grounds
of
design and what was the other council
messenger
an impact
in the countryside impacts on the
character of the area and sustainability
if required and sustainability
okay do we have a secondary
thank you cancer stand
okay and now we can carry on with the
debate members i apologize for any
confusion cause so i'm going councillor
helm first then council thank you madam
chairman first of all i need to declare
i'm not a member of any mafia or any
other association
but for counsellors
um
i don't disagree with what's been said
but my concern is the young people of
this district
where are they going to live
where can they afford to live they can't
afford to live in moulton
my son has had to move get a house in
colchester because he can't afford
anything in this district at all
so that's the question i want to put to
the planning officers where are young
phil going to live
thank you thank you
thank you chairman um
the council
has a requirement to deliver five years
worth of housing land supply we aren't
shouldering our burden in that we're at
3.26 years
that's when the tilted balance comes in
which then means that as a council we
will need to make difficult decisions if
we don't make some difficult decisions
inspectors will make on our behalf um
officers consider this is an application
that should be supported for to certain
along the lines that council helms
raised you know i think we can honestly
say that this application will be up for
approval if we had a five-year land
supply it respected the benefits of the
additional affordable housing but we are
in a situation where we aren't
and there is a high percentage of
football housing where are they going to
live um
but that's up to that's a member's gift
because you determine the applications
uh when they come in officers can you
make the recommendations thank you
thank you chairman yes could i ask you
to sit slightly further back from the
microphone please counsel him because we
get some feedback um
what i have to say to that it's probably
up to mum and dad to find him a house
because no one they can't afford their
own thank you
thank you i'm going to go to councillor
china next and then back to council
messenger uh thank you adam chairman i
agree with actually a lot that's been
said councillor bassinger and i think
actually the first two speakers
um were really on the button with things
that they said
um regarding um in the report it said
about the housing register and a large
number
um
you know people are on the housing
register for all thorn
and i recognize that might be from the
housing services response back when this
application came in
however just like some clarification i'd
like the numbers actually because some
making inquiries and i do agree actually
member of the public has raised this
about um
the housing register numbers and you
know we're talking about affordable
housing here and with all due respect
here we are unsustainable location which
has been proven there was an application
on this site actually which wasn't quite
clear from the report before
and that went down what's been added on
now actually is essentially apart from i
think another property may be the
affordable housing so what we're hinging
this all on is the affordable housing
now my understanding is to get a true
picture of housing requirement for the
um my went with several areas i wanted
to know about doesn't mean to say it
remains the same in fact most people say
malden they want to come to
and latterly in fact when we have um had
it um i i can't say i don't think i'm
giving away confidential information it
was about
a large number of active applicants
within the whole district
but um
and on the register as of today's date
however
the areas mentioned that were
highlighted by applicants didn't include
hawthorne that's my latest information
and certainly when bidding happens
because remember this bidding has to be
involved here
certainly again
um when the bids came in i've got all
the numbers here and areas all thorns
are not mentioned so i'm a bit just
concerned about the housing register
stating a large number of people
are actually stating
author
um i think the first speaker said it all
regarding the spatial strategy
um we know we're not delivering
um
five-year housing land supply at this
current time
however the indica the intended outcomes
of the spatial strategy are entirely
consistent with the mppf
including the need to actually
actively manage patterns of growth to
locations which are sustainable through
limiting the need to travel and offering
genuine choice of transport modes this
site does not in fact a recent appeal
statement in all thorn
actually will tell you all about this
and where the bus stops are and what
they serve and the only
sort of if you like regular service
could be that which is down at
southminster road which is far removed
actually
from this application site
so then we come to weight and
significant weight to the harm that
would arise from the conflict with the
adopted development plans of the space
spatial strategy
and i would think s1 s2 s8 i can come up
with some more i think there's t2
um i also think there's h1 and i1 i
think it is so i think this and um d1 it
might cover them what counselor
bassinger was saying
and we've done
things similar recently look at
southminster there was an application
knightswood
similar sort of thing if you like
unsustainable not connected proof that
we've got to have a footpath even put in
tells you something
taking out historic hedgerow as well for
once for a bit of reason in terms it's
been a very long time
and i do think it is right about the
appearance
of the development
um in terms of the harm it will cause
for the character
and appearance of the area in which the
site actually sits
and also
it will increase the demand for
infrastructure within that part
of the area in terms of
education um and
schools and well there's these schools
isn't it and the gps so there's all that
and that was used actually that was help
formulated with offices over another
application
we refused and it does not constitute
clearly a sustainable relevant and
there'd be no benefits which outweigh
the harm in my opinion now madam
chairman i've heard everyone say we must
go with every application on its own
merits only at a recent south east an
officer said when we were debating one
about
a single residence that we were may had
it rammed down for once a better word i
don't know that rudely that if we
allowed it actually we would be setting
a precedent
stoney hills every time we have an
application for stony hills what do we
hear look what's going on here look
what's going on there look at appeal
decisions you have to take that as a
material consideration
sorry was that something i said humorous
oh right thank you very much i thought i
saw some dialogue and some giggling um
so
to me
i'm just mindful of what's being said in
previous meetings about president madam
chairman i could go on and on i've got a
load of notes here but they're all
coming down i have to say
and bearing in mind essay we do seek to
protect the landscape and natural
resources and ecological value of things
and i think this application goes
against that so i think there are a fair
number of policies within our ldp yes i
hear what mr lee is saying about the
five-year housing land supply but as
i've pointed out our spatial strategy
still is entirely cons considerate i'm
consistent with the mppf including the
need to actively manage patterns of
growth and i'll leave it there at the
moment thank you very much i'm going to
go back to council messenger and then
cancer fluke but first of all i just
want to make comments about the somewhat
nebulous nature of affordable housing
we're not talking about social housing
here we're talking about affordable
housing
for which there is actually no
firm concrete definition
chairman it's in the mppf was it not
just
it's within the mppf and we any section
106 agreement that we sign requires that
the dwelling we would look for we've got
a policy talks about the split and all
things like that so yeah seriously can
you clarify that for me please so what
is exactly the percentage cheaper of an
affordable dwelling in the market
dwelling this is rental which will be
rental or
probably because of the uh temporary but
um
mppf gives a definition of what
affordable housing that includes
affordable rents discount sales uh
sales in relation to where they've
updated the wording and it's basically
used to be key workers but it's been
changed to you need to be able to
demonstrate there's a need for employees
not just any key worker so that has been
slightly changed
there is discount sales first-time
buyers now there is also shared
ownership etc and that's all staked
within the mppf we have
a policy that requires a split of 70 30
i think it is off the cuff and as i said
it's always helpful if i get a heads up
on questions like this
actually i think we've misunderstood
each other not the percentage of
dwellings i want the percentage cheaper
i don't think there's any
our policy would not be looking for this
out for this to be um discount sales
that's not what so this is the point i'm
trying to make is in terms of this
application what does affordable
actually make because council helps help
us make points about the children not
being able to said the first thing i
think is 70 percent of the dwellings
would require to be rental normally and
10
is
but yeah it's not um
we're not looking i think you look
you're not looking at what our policy
requires that's the difference you're in
the air i just thought but i think it
would be useful i certainly would find
it useful so i do apologize members if i
went off piste slightly there but i
think it's helpful to know so i was
going to counsel a passenger then
council flew german could you would you
mi i just wanted to point the clarity
before i come back it might be it might
help counsel the best government
as well um
it was really just a point of clarity
around 7.3 and
some of the comments that councillor
channel made um because clearly
there seemed to be a question again
against those uh
comments that are made by the housing
department now
i i can't think of any other way to put
this to the officer chairman but our the
housing to quote this it says the
housing register contains a significant
number of people
interested in affordable accommodation
in ortho
now that's contrary
to what counselor chan has said
and believes so chairman
i'd like to know what the true position
is and i think based on what the
conversation or the debate you had with
mr lee around what is affordable housing
i'm beginning to think that it might be
a good idea to defer this to enable
somebody from the housing department to
come to this meeting and explain what
the position is jeff
first i'd like to know whether what
stacks up what counselor channel said or
what the housing department said going
to you mr lee please see chairman um
jump back to the point we're talking
about in relation to football housing
and stuff our policy h1
um explains to football housing that
we're normally looking for which goes
more specific than that just required
for the mppf and that highlights it will
be predominantly social rent affordable
rent and intermediate shared ownership
so as i said this would not be a
discount sales while there is an option
for that and the mppf i think for the
guidance now talks about 20 reduction
that isn't what our policy is looking at
we have the ability to
um
take advantage of the definition of the
within the mppf and it may well be in
certain instances we would look to do
that but if we were looking to do that
that would be explicitly laid out to
members so that they were aware that we
were slightly deviating from our policy
but otherwise we'd be looking to just
deliver our usual split of uh social
rent and uh shared ownership properties
as with any other scheme that we've done
across the district so um yeah in
relation to that in relation to cancer
fluka's second ball obviously that was
his first point um
as he said you know
the the housing services advised us you
know as it says in the office's report
that there is a
demand for affordable housing in the
area um
that and that that number is above the
level of properties uh proposed part of
this application
i personally can't expand on any fur
because
that is a consultation response i'm
taking it at face value that the officer
is correct um just like we do with any
other consultant response um but yeah i
can't say any more than that thank you
thank you i mean members do we feel like
we have enough information to go ahead
and listen to this we do i think yes
thank you council championship that was
my point i think i said i was aware of
the housing services response i've got
it here on my um
mobile actually and in fact it does go
on to say that is to be noted the parish
of all thorn is in a designated
protected area dpa under the statutory
entrance number 2098 designated
protector in the feast of england
schedule this restricts occupants i've
only proposed shared ownership units
arising blah blah blah so i've read that
background because i was interested in
it
i have gone um to the housing services
given a list of places i'm interested to
know bearing in mind that housing
register of which all thorn was won and
the response i got from the housing
service so i'm not saying anything else
the same you need to be a bit cautious
when applicants complete the online
application form they have a choice of
selecting individually all areas of
malden or just malden as a whole
most applicants just select malden as a
whole and then wait for a property to be
advertised which will be in the areas
you have listed i will see how the
report pounds out but as mentioned
please be cautious with this as it is
not a true reflection but i will also
shows the total number of housing
register the officer came back and then
said dear councillor channel for the
previous email gave me the whole number
across um the whole district of the
areas you mentioned which were all there
thorns only one i did my own ward
because i'm interested to know my own
ward and also southminster council of
lucas um and it then gave me the numbers
of those areas and the numbers of
applicants that have highlighted those
errors it's then shown me the latest
bidding and how many numbers for each of
ours but all forms not amongst us so i
was just trying to work out the response
given and then that but i feel i've got
enough information because to me um i
think that's a mute point really i know
we're saying
the issue is here the affordable housing
being the issue and i'm sorry for me
the affordable housing numbers which i'm
hearing it's significant i'm sorry
it's only 62 percent the affordable
housing in that area should be for and
that effectively only equates to two
dwellings we're talking about or one
bedroom flat or something so to me
that affordable housing does not
outweigh um the impact of the
development i appreciate the officers
assessment and how they feel but
obviously as a member we can apply the
weight a different way and i'm afraid
mine comes down the other way that even
with the affordable housing it does not
outweigh the impact of that development
thank you thank you very much i'm going
to go back to council master now you
wish to add something thank you i kind
of forgot what i was going to say but i
think i was sort of going back to what
uh council helm was saying about his
consideration for his children or the
young people of uh of that area and all
i can say is it just seems
it just seems ridiculous to put people
on
low income or young people that are
struggling
in an unsustainable area that has
absolutely nothing not a shop not a
school not a hospital absolutely
zero there is nothing there is a
recreation ground with a swing yard as
far as i'm aware and a pub
so you know young people i think want a
lot more for themselves and for their
children and all thorns certainly cannot
provide it
thank you very much
right councillor stan please mine i'm
not going to say a lot because everybody
said more than um what i could possibly
say i've got a little correction to make
and i'd like to ask the person who wrote
the uh um transport statement it says
quite clearly that the journey to
burnham on sea is four hours four
minutes and it's 222 miles so i would
actually ask them to check the accuracy
of the reports they put in before
council
maybe sounds a bit flippant but i'm not
i've taken it seriously because people
read these documents and if they're not
accurate you know they need to be
highlighted that they're not accurate i
admit it could be a copy and paste i
don't know i don't know what it is madam
chair but it's it's quite serious i also
note that um i have looked at this
application that the the affordable
contained the ground floors this
wheelchair which is great but my next
point from that madam chair is it's no
good having a wheelchair there's no
pavement so i call them footpaths
because i'm from the north there's no
footpaths we've been in old thorn today
we've had meetings today about the
highways it is not sustainable to walk
anywhere around that and also it's not
safe at the moment there is no there is
no road that can pavement that you can
push a wheelchair you can't hop on a bus
you know because there aren't any buses
or they're very limited the only ones
you see is the school kiddies which i
think a member said earlier on to go to
the station to even get anywhere it's
very expensive for people if they're you
know an affordable um houses and the
station is so far when you walk down
that hill you take your life in your
hands there as well anyway and the last
time i went i think cancer passenger
could put me right on here and i dropped
down there to help him in election a
long time ago there were so big potholes
you needed to be careful so i mean i
know they're inconsequential and
mr lee will turn around and say they're
not planning reasons counselors stand
but these are
reasons i feel this is what actually
affects so
the the people who are going to live in
there and i also feel that one and
two-bedroomed affordables are not what
we need we need three bedrooms for young
families and then and they need to be in
a more sustainable location so once i
agree and and supported councillor
bassinger it is an inaccessible uh an
accessibility location i think the
impact on the countryside doesn't
mitigate the affordable housing and it
is an unsustainable location and i
totally totally agree with the um um
proposal that council messenger and also
what councillor chana has said is really
important i actually on that housing
department you know i'm a paper person i
do apologize from the climate places i
put
numbers
actual numbers don't produce a report
that we're all supposed to read without
giving us the actual numbers and the
information so that's just something and
i apologize mr lee we should have rang
up to ask about the numbers i know but
some of us don't have time you know and
it's no excuse but you know when i read
this i thought hang on a minute and i
haven't had time to contact anybody and
apologize to the officer um who i maybe
should have rung as well but i certainly
don't support this application thank you
madam chair thank you cancer staff
members we have a seconded proposal
counselor floken
just wanted to answer um chairman i just
wanted to make some comments and i i
feel as though i may well be speaking
against the whole committee here but i i
have been contacted from um some
families in hawthorne and
i i did actually some time ago serve on
ortho parish council and uh it was a
great great pleasure to do so and whilst
i'm talking about the page council i did
notice chairman that they didn't
actually object to the design
of this proposal um but jenna
you know i'd i'd just like to look at
the social side of this really because
affordable housing is usually sought by
people who are on low incomes and by
that i mean from you know from the
possibility of gaining a large mortgage
or something like that from from a
borrowing pet point of view
and and and these would include people
like nurses ambulance staff carers and
other frontline services we found this
happened a lot in bali meadows and uh
and and black water reached the
affordable housing there was massively
oversubscribed we all know how it works
it's offered to people in the village
first and then it just gradually
permeates out
and and these type of properties
allow for families to stay together in
one village you know it's not
necessarily young people that are going
to move into these they could be older
people they could be anybody you know
and it does create a lot of a lot of um
sort of new blood for a village
um and we really need to look at these
schemes you know quite clearly this
application has been said you know it
said it provides 60 affordable units uh
and according to our own housing uh
department much needed in the village
now chairman wherever this goes i really
do think that it might be wise for you
jim to seek clarity over this because
clearly there is some kind of disparity
between what members have gained as
information as what the housing
department have said and i think you
know i do know that there's a lot of
people who are desperate for affordable
housing in the district and they've
looked at this and and i'm sure that
they're they're hoping for a better
outcome than i feel might happen tonight
but
the seat the scheme would uh make a
positive contribution to to the uh 0.1
shortfall in the five-year housing
management i tried to work out what that
means actually one point
five five four point nine percent over
over five years at roughly 330 houses a
year and i sort of got got to a figure
and i think we're sleeping chairman
you're about a year out of date or not
in eight oh about six months about 3.26
now well do you know i was told that
today but i thought i read in here it
was 4.9 and i was going to commend you
so we've got a massive shortfall in
other words it's a lot worse than what i
thought so chairman if this if this
committee
if this committee was was
mindful
chairman
to support the officer's recommendation
to approve it would give eight families
a fabulous opportunity to get their own
properties and and and i and i say that
german because i don't think there's
going to be many more opportunities
coming forward
um
tilted balance is a wonderful thing and
i i guess i was surprised as everybody
else when i read the recommendation on
this but this is a professional opinion
in the offices
you know at the end of the day that has
to be recognized whether we agree with
it or not it's still a professional
opinion
um so chairman i think based on that uh
i would find it hard
uh even with the
differences of opinion about whether
these properties are required or not in
author i find this hard really to go
against the officer's recommendation and
not least all because it would allow for
a low-income families to get on the
housing
ladder however you expect you know
however it happens and if it doesn't
come here
uh where's it gonna come you know we we
know let's be sensible another 200
houses in the pipeline for for burnham
another 200 in the pipeline for
southminster
you know i don't have any intelligence
from around malden but i guess that's
similar
thousand
you're about to talk oh yes
you know they they just these are all
rocking and rolling and coming forward
you know and we're going to have to try
and control this and the only way we
could control it is to try and get some
developments perhaps like this and
members will know that when we did the
local development plan last time pepper
potting was always more favorable than
putting a thousand in burnham you know
spread the houses around the district
you know that was always favorable so
chairman you've already got a proposal
on the table and i've said i can't
support it and and i'm so i don't know
if you can hear me whilst the channel
and uh council stamp having their own
debate across the chamber but i'll uh
i'll uh i'll stop there and enjoy the
support my friend councillor morrison i
can catch it
i can hear you counselor
we all love these debates and everything
else and a bit of banter but we've got
to understand that we're in different
times now these microphones pick up
everything and people are trying to
listen right now on
youtube and then all the other chats
probably tick tock as well
thank you thank you i did cancel i'm
going to go connect can i just point to
clarity i just really just um i'm not
going to apologize to councillor luca
for actually um
um he mentioned something about pepper
potting now i i understand it was the
previous administration and the ldp who
didn't allow the pepper potting now we
won't have a cross chamber debate but
that's why i was seeking clarity thank
you thank you i'm going to know i'm
going to go to council dueck now and
then i'm going to give a final rights
reply to world member council passenger
and then i'm going to go to a boat
because we have gone on at length about
this
now
i don't think i know enough about this
application that stands at the moment i
think i
probably reflect that but what i would
like to say is
voice that young a lot of young people
in the villages want to remain in the
villages they don't want them to the
bright part they don't want to go
away from their families they want to
stay
we have been very neglectful in this
council over the last few years in
supplying villages i mean villages
and towns bigger towns
supplying small villages
with housing for
young people i
am well aware in my board for all sorts
of ways that that's been
attempted by members of the public to
get round they
families jobs and other reasons
sustainability
we must add members recognize that we
must do something about it i'm not
saying this is the right application one
way or the other but that is something
we must do we will stop saying probably
kids don't want to leave the kids only
want to leave because they can't not
stay
and that is the very good reflection of
my last cats
thank you i'm going to go to council
bassinger now and then members please
and thank you very much
and i would just like to say that again
you know i i believe people do want to
stay probably in the rural areas close
to their families but
sticking them in an area what is
unsustainable i don't think has any
advantages at all
as far as work is concerned traveling to
hospitals as council flukes said for
nurses i don't think that that is an
option whatsoever there's nothing nearby
there's nothing there is getting to the
station would be a nightmare for anybody
a nurse doesn't necessarily have a car
so therefore you know how would she get
to work it just creates huge problems
uh people also you say people want to
live in villages of course they do but
then you know no one wants to be a farm
worker we're not farm workers so there's
nothing here for them
all terrible it's a fact you know young
people want to go where there's life
they don't want to be stuck in areas
where there's nothing and this in my
opinion is totally unsuitable i don't
need any clarity this doesn't need to be
deferred i think we need to make an
absolute stance here and refuse this
application
thank you i am now going to vote members
so we have a proposal which is that we
go against the officer's recommendation
and we refuse this application record
your vote please madam chairman recorded
vote
yes
i have a secondary counsellor passenger
and all council staff i'm not quite sure
who got in there first
that's a passenger i think so um
thank you chairman we're going to have a
recorded vote members um to refuse the
application contrary to the obstacles oh
sorry bear with me
just as a point of good practice um
should a third reason for you should be
added in relation to lack of signs
section 106 agreement
which is just a good practice for
um with determination application like
this
madam chairman can i just check that
actually the reasons refusal will cover
things like s1 s8
and housing policy i i won and from what
we've heard about the transport strategy
appearing to be burnham on c
um to do with transport uh there's a
policy there
so i i think we need to ensure we do and
the d1 because council passenger felt
about the design impact and everything
so i just want assurances
those sort of large span of policy
numbers are
contained within those reasons of
refusal
chairman
the refugee will
contain the standard suite of conditions
that relate to issues such as design
sustainability and impact on the caps
the area yes thank you chairman and the
transport thank you
thank you
so vote please
thank you chairman we're going to take a
recorded vote now to refuse the
application contrary to the officer's
recommendation of approval for the
reasons as outlined impact on the
character of the area design
sustainability and the suite of issues
that mr lee has referenced
members i will call your names in
alphabetical order can you state clearly
for against or abstain
starting with counselor passenger
against the application
i'll go either way
okay okay members
council messenger is for the refusal
thank you
councillor beale
councillor bell for
counsellor boyce
councillor channer or
councillor dueck
councillor fluker
based on what the residents of author
told me today against
thank you council helm
council hall
against
cancer stamp paul
thank you members that's six for the
refusal two against the refusal and two
abstentions that's carried
members thank you very much that was um
i hated debate
so that brings us on to item seven which
is twenty one zero zero six
of course thank you very very much
councillor tubic
enjoy the rest of your evening no he's
just for clarity i'm taking him home so
take your time
moving forward members item seven twenty
one zero zero six eight two four modern
hill vicarage lane london
there is a members update for this which
i trust you have all seen and the
presenter is so prepared again so over
to you mistaken rest
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a covered cattle yard
for the purposes of animal welfare
the development would cover the cattle
pens and would have internal led
lighting hanging from the ridge of the
roof
this is the location plan showing the
site outlined in red and the area of the
proposed cattle cover
the proposed block plan again showing
the development in yellow
the proposed elevations
the proposed floor plans
some photos of the site from ground
level
and some aerial views of the whole site
it's not considered that development
would harm the character of the area or
impact on neighbouring sites or highway
safety and is therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you mistakers so just to clarify
there is already a cow shed in this um
place it just doesn't have a roof on it
so this application is just to put a
roof onto the cowshed councillor boyce
then councillor flicker
um thank you chairman as you see i
called this in not because i've got any
problems uh
with it
i agree but i i believe that there were
one or two issues that needed uh
clarifying um and certainly lighting was
one of them which has been
um
uh
resolved or explained
um
the highway
issue
uh was that i had intelligence that uh
movements were going to be
rather than uh on the holding
would be
along the road it's a very narrow
lane this isn't necessarily
a good thing but there i can see that
there will be no way you could condition
that because highway said no problem
anyway
um
the other issue is although there's
reference to it in a an informative or
somewhere within the report which i
can't put my finger on at the moment um
but which i think is a major
consideration and that is there doesn't
seem to be a condition for the treatment
of waste
thank you councilman can i ask um
officers to come back on that before i
go to cancer plunker please
thank you alex
yes so um
the use is already established and
matters of waste in terms of
some of the issues that have been raised
are matter
excuse me more for the environment
agency
and for uh environmental health
in terms of this particular case it is
simply providing
a shelter above the already established
use
thank you does that answer your question
so thank you chairman and as i said i'm
quite happy with the recommendation
super thank you council of newcastle
yeah thank you chairman i i i i i know a
little bit about this business because i
know where it morphed from and and um
you know i know that there are several
young contractors people interested in
farming who want to stay in here and
they
actually rent properties i believe
around tillingham because they can't get
affordable ones but chairman being
[Music]
an operation of livestock myself i i can
see where this
where
that burst
it's the principle and i know that you
would agree with that and you're welcome
to come and see my hebrew dean's any
time um
chairman this is a welfare this is a
welfare issue uh you know i feel for
councillor duke sitting outside on his
own it looks to me like a pretty
straightforward application and that
said german i propose that we agree the
officer's recommendation thank you
thank you i think we have several
seconders i'm not sure who we'd like to
choose we'll go for councillor hell
i feel members we may be able to agree
this by a sense am i right
super thank you very much so that brings
us on to item 8 i have no other items of
business that are urgent you'll be
pleased to hear so at
21 12 i close this meeting
thank you all very much and do drive
safely
thank you very much officers